hey here's something I want to briefly
touch on yesterday the Dow Jones
Industrial Average closed above 20,000
for the first time ever and if you
looked at right-wing media you would
have thought that this not only
represented some incredible economic
achievement but also that Donald Trump
was the savior that led to such a major
economic achievement if you looked at
Drudge Report or Fox News just
everywhere praise for Trump Donald
Trump's own son Eric Trump actually
tweeting about Dow 20k saying amazing
and he is just getting started hashtag
Dow 20k I hate to slow the roll of some
of these trumpets for a second here but
we let's break this down and figure out
what's going on number one yes yesterday
the Dow Jones Industrial Average closed
up 253 points from when Donald Trump
took over as president on January 20th
that represents a gain of one point two
eight percent in for trading days that's
about a third of a percentage point per
trading day I want to remind you that
under President Obama the Dow Jones
Industrial Average gained a hundred and
thirty nine percent meaning that it more
than doubled
where were the Conservatives when
President Obama oversaw one of the
greatest stock market rallies in a very
very long time oh I can tell you where
they were Pat they were either saying
that Obama had nothing to do with it or
saying that the Dow Jones Industrial
Average isn't reflective of the strength
of the economy and both are partially
true but the same logic is not being
applied to Donald Trump 20,000 is an
arbitrary number and the Dow Jones
Industrial Average is price weighted
versus market cap weighted so to give a
very crude example of this if you buy if
you buy one banana at the grocery store
for a dollar and you buy I don't know
100 ice cream cones at $10 each
the average price between ice cream
cones and the banana is going to be
exactly half away 50 between $1 and $100
but that doesn't mean that you had half
of your spending go tour
the bananas and half of the spending go
towards the ice cream cones maybe a
little bit of a crude example but the
point is 20k doesn't tell us anything
per se i as a people know basically
invest in index funds so I am sensitive
to the changing prices values of indices
like the NASDAQ and Dow Jones and sp500
Excel etc but what I want to remind you
is that my response now is the same as
it has been under other presidents
stocks tend to do better under
Democratic presidents the stock market
is not the be-all end-all for assessing
the economy but it is one metric that we
have and will continue to look at the
hypocrisy though is what's stunning here
and it gives us big insight into the
mind of a trumpet because they celebrate
a 1% gain under Trump do they praise
Obama for more than doubling the stock
market I don't hear it yeah I think
you've hit on all the major points there
it was interesting because after Donald
Trump won the election there was
speculation that the stock market would
drop yeah that wasn't the case but we
know just from history that the market
does better under Democratic presidents
sure so if I was to predict I would
guess that the market at some point
would start to go down again yeah you're
predicting the stock market something
that many many people try to do and we
can legitimately wonder how good anybody
can be at predicting the movement of the
stock market over a very long period of
time but remember this ownership in the
stock market is highly highly
concentrated in the u.s. particularly
among the wealthier what I think we need
to agree on is that we have many
indicators that alone aren't the
indicator of economic strength strength
and many of these indicators are
somewhat related to the policy of the
President and all taken together they
can paint a broader picture for us of
how the economy is doing maybe that's
too nuanced and boring for some trumpets
though they'd rather ignore a hundred
and thirty nine percent gains under
Obama and cheerlead one percent gains
under trump like he's the second coming
of Jesus or something else for lack of a
better term send me your thoughts I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman in doe Chino is
sponsoring today's episode of the David
Pakman show they are one of the largest
made-to-measure menswear brands they
have a number of North American
showrooms I went to the Boston showroom
and worked with Chris who took all of my
measurements and offered me way more
choices than I knew what to do with for
fabric button choices lapels lining etc
and four weeks later I had a custom made
to measure suit the exact way that I
wanted it now if you don't live near one
of the nine showrooms in North America
you can go to the endo chino website you
can pick through hundreds of fabrics
patterns lapels pleats jacket linings
etc you submit your measurements which
you can take yourself at home and then
you just wait and then a custom stylish
suit shows up four weeks later and this
week david pakman show listeners can get
any premium Indo Chino suit for three
hundred and eighty nine dollars at endo
chino comm if and this is a major if you
enter the code Pakman at checkout that
is 50% off the regular price for a
made-to-measure premium suit plus
shipping is free endo chino comm promo
code pakman for any premium suit for
three eighty nine and free shipping stop
worrying about those badly fitting suits
or expensive trips to the tailor endo
chino comm promo code pakman